so we're gonna talk today about
universal JavaScript and a vision I
personally have and we'll just start
with saying hello Bonjour oh this is a
cat I really like this that's all
my name is Myles and I'm a developer
advocate at Google focused on the
node.js ecosystem and Google cloud
platform you know I always put this at
the bottom of this slide just saying hey
this is my own opinions so you know it
take it or leave it
but I'll take it a step further this
time and say you know the opinions
expressed in this talk may even be wrong
I don't know but what I can promise you
is the opinions in this talk are
definitely opinions and that and that's
about the level of commitment I'm
willing to make on them but so you may
be asking the question of like what even
is universal JavaScript it's a pretty
broad term and so I cheated and I wrote
a tweet and asked other people to answer
it for me and we we got a wide variety
of responses this was what many of you
may be thinking right now because
without any context
I'd say it's meaningless Universal means
different things to different people you
can get an idea of the positive response
I'm getting here someone playing
buzzword bingo so that's always fun
1998 called and once it's optimism back
and this actually came in two separate
forms from two separate people I think
this is you could say the same thing in
a different way it was such a hype idea
a decade ago - I even got quotes we did
buy a horse J ass which made my whole
week I love it when that happens but
some people in my personal opinion just
got it like they they have that same
vision code just works in the browser an
ode and I don't have to think very hard
no build step necessary across both the
web and node not having to transpile
code to multiple targets write once run
everywhere this is great I'm hiring this
person to do marketing for me this is
very succinct very to the point and you
may be asking yourself is this different
than isomorphic JavaScript and the
answer is clearly yes and this is going
to talk about isomorphic JavaScript so
I'm not going to get too much into it
but isomorphic javascript is a term that
actually it was created in 2011 so when
people were saying oh you have the
optimism of a decade ago they're not
exaggerating and and this blog post
written by Charlie Robbins who's a board
member of the open J's foundation
potentially somewhere in this room
coined the term isomorphic JavaScript
and you can find this from the wayback
machine you if you're reading the small
text which you probably can't you'll
notice that it does talk about the idea
of running JavaScript both on the client
and the server but one of the things
that was fundamentally different about
the concept devised amorphic javascript
it was heavily heavily tied to the
concept of the view and model view
controller and which patterns of
designing single page applications could
be run on the server for server-side
rendering you know nine years ago it was
just as hard as today maybe a little
harder to serve a site that was
primarily JavaScript and actually have
any sort of machine like know what it's
doing without running the code and it
also creates like a really slow time to
first paint and this talk is not about
any of those things and I would argue
that universal JavaScript is while it's
similar
morphic javascript is a fundamentally
different thing and we'll dig into that
a bit but universal JavaScript and its
new tagline runs once run anywhere and I
bet all of you are now thinking
Universal JavaScript is great and you
want me to actually tell you about it so
I'm going to the first thing that's
important about the concept of universal
JavaScript and running everywhere is
thinking about all the places you may
want to actually run your code so
obviously we've got browsers and node
we've already mentioned that but there's
a lot of other places where you might be
running JavaScript as well denno is a
fantastic new platform that Ryan Dahl
the creator of node has come up with has
some different concepts and different
thoughts about how JavaScript would work
different api's we have edge workers a
great product from CloudFlare that is
running javascript on the edge of a CDN
it's API is designed heavily after the
serviceworker api it has fetch but it's
kind of its own subset it's its own run
time it has its own opinions about how
to run execute and debug JavaScript
moddable is a really cool one for
embedded systems it's a version of
JavaScript that you can run on tiny
chips and put anywhere moddable
implements their own API is they also
implement the entire language itself as
far as I know moddable actually already
influenced top-level oh8 and is one of
the most compliant JavaScript engines
out there it's actually probably a good
time to stop for a second and say that
all of the the ones above
aside from browsers a lot of those are
using v8 the JavaScript engine from
chrome model is not it's using its own
JavaScript engine that they manage
themselves and we'll see we see a lot of
other places where javascript is showing
up as well embedded inside of databases
you can also see it inside of
productivity software all sorts of ways
of scripting things and automating
things in ways you wouldn't have
imagined and JavaScript is showing up
all over the place and to me this is one
of the reasons why Universal javascript
is so important when we're writing our
libraries or we're writing our
productivity tools or we're moving
between these different environments we
don't necessarily know where the code
we're writing is going to end up we
don't even know who's going to use it so
kind of starting from this principle of
a baseline that
can be shared everywhere make sure that
your codes extensible make sure it can
be shared in different places all of
these environments share parts there are
not these fundamentally different things
we have standards we align along a
baseline and the the core of all of that
is equity - 6 - which is specified by
tc39
the standards organization that
specifies the JavaScript language and
within Etna - 6 - if you look into the
spec there's a couple concepts that I
won't get too much into right now of
realms intrinsics and primordial x' and
this is like the soup that makes up the
core of JavaScript realms are the
context where your code runs I'm
bluffing over it but find me later for
more details intrinsics are all the
different built-ins that are available
on the global object that you can change
and you can use and primordial are the
ones that are necessary to even
bootstrap the environment so some
examples of primordial x' would be like
array and number and object and function
without these instantiated in the
environment you can't even make the
higher-level things like some of the
namespace objects such as json and math
and reflect these these api's are all
available in every single JavaScript
runtime these are all standardized by
equi - 6 - but they serve slightly
different purposes
something like JSON or math or date are
almost more like libraries within
JavaScript whereas things like object
our core capabilities one of the cool
things about these these are all
intrinsic node has done some work
recently and freezing all of these
objects because you don't want some
random module changing the way that node
does things internally this is an
example of a way that a platform can do
small changes to the way it works above
the baseline runtime without really
causing major differences for people but
one of the things that tc39 specified
you know in the recent future of five
years ago was es modules and prior to es
modules
there was no common way to share code
between all of these different
environments if you wanted to take one
piece of code and link it to another
piece of code you are either literally
concatenating the files together or
running a tool such as Babel or roll-up
or web pack to pack everything together
so you could run it node was one of the
few environments that had a built in
module system which was common j/s which
is what a lot of other runtimes copied
but it was not standardized and it
wasn't common jeaious itself wasn't
built in a way that browsers could use
as well yes modules made some
compromises didn't make everyone happy
but was something that all of these
different environments can share and I
would like to push it a step further and
say that modules have been the missing
piece to really enable universal
JavaScript without modules as kind of
this shared way of sharing code we were
destined to have to transpile we had to
do some sort of function on the code in
order to use it in different places but
that's where things get kind of weird
because even though es modules are
specified in Ethne the loader itself is
not the loaders implemented by the
embedder so in node.js we implement the
loader and the chromium browser blink
implements the loader and tc39 also
leaves it up to the hosting environment
to determine resolution how do we take
that string that you give that says hey
I want this thing and find it it's up to
the runtime to turn a reference into a
location to fetch a resource from that
location to do this recursively and
build a graph and give the engine the
entire graph to execute this core piece
of shared infrastructure which is
standardized has this single place where
every single runtime can make their own
decisions in bv8 this single place where
you're actually saying hey here's the
code I'm sharing this is one of the
reasons that in the ESM implementation
of node were pushing towards removing
some of the magic from common j/s that
browsers will that won't be capable in
the browsers this is a potential place
of platform divergence and platform
divergence is something that gives me
existential dread and a known side
effect about existential dread is that
it causes nihilistic transpilation this
is a term I coined myself recently
nihilistic transpilation is when you
have so given up on the concept of
universal JavaScript where you've so
bought into the fact that we're always
going to need to build we're always
going to need to transpile that
universal JavaScript doesn't even matter
anymore it's not a priority it's not a
thing that needs to be thought about
it's just not possible we may as well
just you know accept our transformation
gods and move forward and it's built on
this idea in my personal opinion that
javascript platforms are potentially
fundamentally different I would say that
they're not fundamentally different but
they can have drastically different
api's which is fine different platforms
have different needs that doesn't mean
that the core language needs to be
different and people may ask that
question is the browser fundamentally
different from nodejs and yes it's api's
are gonna be fundamentally different but
they do come from the same soup they
have the same primordial x' they have
the same base language they have the
ability to have this shared core in fact
nodejs has adapted many of the api is
designed originally for browsers so if
you look at a standards organization
like what working group you may think to
yourself aren't what working group of
standards standards breath
browser specific so they standardize
HTML and they standardize dom and those
aren't things that no does although with
server-side rendering maybe it does I
guess note as a platform doesn't but we
do have what working group standards api
is in both run way run times and i have
an asterisks there because they differ a
little bit but we're trying but
something like console or URL or the
encoder api these are all things that
are standardized at what working group
that we have in node i think you'd be
very hard-pressed to find a JavaScript
runtime that's easy to use that doesn't
have console in it hat like
that's how ID bug like if you don't have
console you're kind of like how do you
even get started and there's even other
standards that aren't yet in nodejs that
we're exploring I know people say stop
trying to make fetch happen I'm not
gonna stop trying to make fetch happen
I want fetch to happen but this is a
really great example of one of those ap
is that like on the surface from an API
perspective most developers like that's
great I give a string to a function and
it gives me a promise and then that
promise is gonna give me the thing that
I asked for but under the hood there's
so many subtle differences between node
and the browser the browser only really
ever has one tenant you're not worried
about multiple people making requests
and node the same process may have
requests from 10 20 a hundred different
people you can't share the state of the
fetch object in the same way it can
create security concerns but should
those plumbing problems be something
that means we don't have shared API
surface what working group streams is
another great example here Matteo Kalina
who I believe is in the audience
somewhere has been exploring in getting
what working group streams support in
node whether or not we get stream
support in node I think that there's
definitely a possibility of finding ways
to have a communication layer between
the two so that node streams in what
working group streams can talk but like
these kinds of fundamental differences
in the platform make it hard to see that
future of universal JavaScript and makes
it easy to fall into that pit of
nihilistic transpilation and I mentioned
the interface versus plumbing and I
think that this is so important as
platform developers as library
developers and in framework developers
when you are designing api's the
plumbing matters in the plumbing is all
you're working on and it's really easy
to lose track of everything else but to
many people who are consuming what
you're using what they care about is the
interface how am i calling into that
thing does it work the way that I'm
expecting it to work and I think for a
world of universal JavaScript we need to
be thinking more about the interface
than the plumbing platforms can worry
about the plumbing as long as the
behavior is similar enough if developers
have shared in
faces we can get a lot done and that
starts to ask kind of like this question
of like where does the platform begin we
have those intrinsic some primordial zat
what point does it become the platform
is console part of the platform is it
part of the runtime where does the
platform end when does it start becoming
the part that is frameworks like these
are these are a lot of words and maybe
you know maybe it's a little too broad
but I think it's really important to
think about these things we're all using
these tools what part is the language
what part is the platform what part of
the frameworks why do I care about these
things and where is the code that I'm
writing fitting into this picture and I
want to suppose that perhaps Universal
JavaScript is a platform concern in a
great example here is JSON modules how
many people here have ever required JSON
before in node you can just require JSON
and it gives you an object and it's a
really great experience in the browser
if you want to get JSON right now you
have to fetch it which all of a sudden
introduces a promise and it complicates
things
so inspired by nodejs JSON modules were
actually specified in the HTML spec by
what working group but it was rejected
at T PAC for security concerns T pack
being the conference of w3c as a
response to this there's a proposal at
TC 39 working on module attributes to
try to handle the security concerns that
were raised by the w3c the reason that I
bring this all up is that Universal
needs to be a platform ethos the idea
that we could have JSON modules and have
a shared interface for JSON modules
across every single runtime requires all
of these different partners in the web
ecosystem to work together for you know
shared good and there are a lot of these
standards happening at tc39 we're
exploring built-in modules and standard
libraries and module attributes these
are all things that will bring us closer
to a future of of universal JavaScript
at what working group they're they're
exploring JSON modules at the w3c
they're exploring import Maps which will
allow bear imports in the browser and
huazi which would be a shared system
interface
that can be used across many runtimes
with webassembly but with all this work
happening in different places how do we
find a shared vision and this isn't a
question that I have an answer to today
this is a question that I think we as a
group need to be thinking about where do
we collaborate when we have all of these
disparate stakeholders where do we all
come to collaborate together in that
question that we started with our
various JavaScript platforms
fundamentally different I would say that
developers shouldn't have to know about
that beyond an API developer skills
should be portable and to me that's one
of the most powerful things about the
concept of universal and I think it's
one of the reasons why a platform like
node was so successful portable skills
and I would even go as far as to say
Universal needs to be a platform concern
and not a development target this needs
to be something that fundamentally we
are all working towards Universal it's a
goal not a technique and I'll end on a
pretty bold note that I think the future
of JavaScript needs to be universal if
javascript is to have a future
thank you I'm Myles and this is a
surfing dog
[Applause]